I would define compassion in a nutshell
as a natural sense of concern that
arises in us in the face of someone who
is in need or someone who's in pain and
accompanied by a kind of a wishing to
see the relief or end of that situation
and wanted to do something about it
so it's compassion it's not just an
emotional reaction there is also a more
motivational kind of you know element
which makes us want to do something
about the situation one of the
interesting thing about our contemporary
modern society is that given the highly
competitive nature of society and also
the way in which we bring out our
children and the way in which we
ourselves grew up which involved huge
amount of evaluation and judgments and
comparison across with others from a
very very early age we have kind of
internalized a certain kind of way of
being in the world and perceiving our
relationship with others and that
dynamic has created a certain kind of
you know inhibitions against our natural
compassionate instinct so and these
inhibitions really take primarily in the
form of fear so for example many people
worry and are afraid that if they are
too kind in too compassionate that other
people will take advantage of them they
will see them as pushover or weak or
losers so that's one type of fear that
we bring another type of fear that we
bring is that you know because in
popular understanding of compassion it's
so dominated by compassion as an emotion
kind of a soft heart and tender heart
and so on so people worry that if they
allow their compassionate and kinder
instinct to become more dominant in
their way of interacting with the world
and others you know somehow it might
undermine their more rational tougher
side so that they may not be able to
succeed in the life and compete that's
another type of fear and then sometimes
in intimate relations particularly you
know between
parents and children on the part of the
parents sometimes we also worry that if
we are too kind to our children you know
we might be spoiling them
you know we they might become over
dependent upon us and then somehow we
will end up having to do everything for
them so these are various types of fear
that we bring into our expression of
natural compassion of the instinct and a
lot of these are subconscious biases
that we bring you know people may not
necessarily sit down and think that's
what I'm going to do but these are
culturally acquired sensibilities and
biases which also makes us suspicious
when someone is being kind to us
compassionate towards us we start
wondering there must be hidden agenda
you know that that person must want
something from me
so it's unvaried these are various forms
of culturally acquired fear that really
undermines the expression what is really
natural to our you know human being
which is the ability to connect with
someone the ability to relate to that
person at a deeper level and have a much
more open heart hearted kind of
interaction
you